- [Voiceover] So let's just think about
what confidence level means.
That means, remember the
median's gonna be some number.
It might be, you know, the
actual median hourly wage
for physical therapists,
might be $30 an hour
or $25 an hour.
They're trying to estimate it
by doing this random selection
and then they're providing a range,
and they're saying, "Hey,
"there's some confidence level
"that this range captures
"that true median hourly wage."
So when they say there's
a 95% confidence level,
they're saying that
there's a 95% probability
that the true median is
between these two numbers.
Now if we're talking about
a 90% confidence level,
if we're talking about
that means we are less confident
that the true median is
between these two numbers.
In order to be less confident,
you would want to have
even a narrower range.
You would want a range that is a subset
of this range right over here.
Let me make this clear.
So,
the range is $22.76
all the way to $59.24.
So when they say it's
a 95% confidence level
that means,
let me actually draw a number line here.
So let's say these are just
points on the number line.
These are points on the number line,
so that's $22.76, this is $59.24.
They're 95% confident
that the true median,
that the true median is going to be
that is going to be
between these two values.
So, they're 95% confident
the true median is there,
that the true median is there,
but there's still a 5% chance
that maybe the true median could be here.
It could be below this range
or above this range.
Now, if we're talking about
a lower confidence level,
90% confidence level,
that means that this range
should be narrowed.
If you're gonna be less confident,
that means you want,
or the only way you're
gonna be less confident
is if you have a narrower range.
If you had a broader range,
if it went from say here to here,
you'd be even more confident.
This type of range,
you might have a 97% confidence level.
So at 90% less confident,
you're looking at something
that might look something like that.
Now, let's look at the choices.
So this is actually more like this one.
You're starting lower
and you're ending higher.
So you should be even more...
If you're 95% confidence
that this range captured it,
you should be even more confident
that this range captured it.
So this would actually
maybe be at 97 or 98,
who knows, confidence level,
not a 90% confidence level,
so we can rule that out.
So this one's interesting
because it starts lower
but then it ends lower, too.
So I don't know what you could actually,
what you could say,
it's based on the same...
Yeah, I don't know.
This one's a little bit...
It depends kind of
what the distribution
that you selected was.
They didn't tell us a lot about that.
This is a little bit, I don't know.
This one feels a little bit shady.
Well, this is also similar.
It starts a little bit lower
and then it ends a little bit lower.
So, it's kind of a shift in the range
and so this is also...
I wouldn't, you know,
you don't know for sure
that you're going to have, I mean,
you're probably going to have a...
Well, they don't tell us a
lot about the distribution,
so I'm not gonna make too
many statements there.
So that's going to be something like...
That's going to be actually like from here
to here.
This is going to be a narrower range,
so you would be less confident.
So, this could be something
that represents a 90%,
a 90% confidence level.
So actually I would go with this one,
'cause this is kind of a purely...
This is a subset of the previous range
so I like this choice
right over here.